and and the biggest scam is is what i
saw coming down the hatch with the nba
right and not to go backwards but to to
to encapsulate and end my nba story with
my my anxiety was really existential
my anxiety was to say that there's a
global corporate community
and that the nba is a watering hole for
a global corporate community
they're like the cinequan of globalism
you were saying that back then oh yeah
go pull it up i mean you pull up the
sports illustrated articles i'm saying
this is a global corporate community
this isn't just a basketball league this
is every industry in the entire world
from here to beijing represented
in a financial interest
and when they say mental health is not
important they're saying the human
condition isn't important and it was a
pretext for their partners their
corporate partners such as big tech
to be predatory around human psychology
to weaponize dopamine against the
average person and that is what they've
done and the nba knew it back then